reject nation hello this has become the daily
show i am jon stewart i am very excited about
this being so often how much you guys have loved
this show we have breaking news and frankly this
couldn't wait for the other things but before
we get into that please do like subscribe leave
comments because koi's comic corner is largely
going to be fueled by you you're like my co-host
things you want to hear about i'm going to
dive into i've already got some ideas of future
episodes so those comments are being perused
enjoyed and very much appreciated but today
with the giant news that broke we're going to be
talking about the rumors that are probably true
about lady gaga joining joker 2 what that
means for the other rumors the willem dafoe
rumors how that might tie into the title
itself these rumors of it being a musical
how greg called this four months ago and most of
all what i think this is going to be influenced
by with the comic books can you tell that greg's
sitting immediately in my left that's him giggling
i'm very excited because this to me elevates
the sequel idea of what joker 2 is going to be
we're going to dive into all of that
and more after these opening credits
and we're back i'm so excited for joker 2 now that
we have this big big rumor the combination of it
being lady gaga and potentially a musical elevates
this whole thing but let's break down what we've
seen so far we know the title of this film is
joker felix my last name is french unfortunately
i am not as per the pronunciation that millions
of french people just suffered through i'm so
sorry france foley aju means the madness of two
so many of us had assumed that meant the willem
dafoe rumors were in fact true during the no way
home press tour willem dafoe was very very open
about the fact that yes he knows he looks like
the joker and yes he knows we have all been fan
casting him for quite some time so much so he had
it as part of his snl opening monologue that to me
was locking in the fact we were getting willem
dafoe opposite joaquin phoenix because basically
the plot of the first joker movie the the moral
foundation it stood on was what is society what
is culture what does it mean when we live in a
world of nihilism where that might be the answer
how does anarchy really differ from a
lot of the choices we make when we ignore
others in society whether you love or
hate the joker movie it has a lot to say
and i really think the joker character has a
lot to say so in that same vein willem dafoe was
seemingly going to be playing a character that
followed in the footsteps of the joker he followed
the lead of the joker just as the third act of the
film seemed to represent they could have even had
willem dafoe photoshopped into that last bit they
could have easily started the film with you know
one of the guys that's in that mob being william
defoe it seemed like a really cut and dry way to
do a sequel and it seemed like an incredible idea
all that being said this might be an even better
idea because it seemingly came out of nowhere
except greg four months ago he's gonna put a
link there he's gonna take the credit he deserves
it four months ago greg said hey there's some lady
gaga rumors what if she's harley quinn but we're
hearing these rumors about lady gaga when we're
looking at who lady gaga might be i'm not opposed
to the idea of her actually being harlene quinzel
in arkham asylum with this madness of two it looks
to be a love story now that we have lady gaga
i no longer believe we're getting the willem dafoe
movie or it's in conjunction with this but in a
smaller way it'd be cool to see the idea of the
commentary of another joker as maybe a stepping
stone maybe you do that beautiful thing where
you've got like a minor villain leading up to the
full story maybe you include that idea or you play
around with the idea of willem dafoe as someone
who's trying to take credit for some of the things
that joaquin has done either way i think if they
do involve willem it won't be the main crux of
the film anymore i think this love story between
harley and joker is the exact right way to go with
a sequel about reality and perception remember the
first joker movie had a lot of questions about how
much of that was in his head how much of that was
in the asylum what better type of story to tell
than one about love what clouds our minds more
than the psychology of love what makes us think
we're feeling and seeing and experiencing things
more than love he's already in the asylum he meets
harley quinn she's his therapist we can live in
a sequel that's full david lynchian that's got
shades of fincher that plays with all of those
tropes in the same way that the first one played
in the world of scorsese i honestly think when the
first one had those scorsese parallels this next
one is gonna go lynch and fincher i think it's
gonna be a question of what reality is i think
it's gonna be a question of what love makes us do
i think it's gonna be a question of how much is
from the perception of joker and how much is it
the versions of reality he's telling harley quinn
and how long into the story do we start to see it
from harley quinn's world view i could easily see
this being a story of harleen quinzel going into
harley quinn easily this being a story of harleen
quinzel giving us a subjective or uh objective
view of the world that then becomes subjective
once she's harley quinn i think we're gonna see a
reality distortion through the journey of this and
that's when the musical takes off i think we're
gonna be in an augmented reality through all these
songs and you cast lady gaga you've got someone
who is a powerhouse actress who happens to be one
of the great singers of our time someone who is
so good in that bradley cooper joint she was
up for an oscar and hadn't even acted that much
i honestly think this could be the thing that
elevates this beyond the first movie's billion
dollar budget i personally thought you shouldn't
make a sequel to the first joke i thought it was a
beautiful else world that had a young bruce wayne
keeping it from tying in to the batman mythology i
thought it was very smart that they consciously
showed wayne manor they consciously had thomas
wayne as a bit of a prick because you could easily
have this be like oh he's going to fight robert
pens and batman no that would like basically
devalue both properties instead you draw hardline
in the sand you make sure it stays in elseworld
but i thought they could leave it alone i thought
that was kind of the best way to have that because
then dc can start doing batman by gaslight it can
start doing earth 2 superman it can start doing
these alternate realities and a sequel kind of
makes it seem like we've got this whole other
universe they're going to live in but this
this gives you the opportunity to have the else
world feels like it's growing organically you've
got the unreality of the musical you've got the
elevation of a sequel you've got the inherent
need to make something bigger is undermined by
not making it flashier in the cheesy sense in
the action spectacle but literally flashy in that
it's a musical this is such an inspired move and
it gives us a harley quinn we've never seen before
we've got margot robbie as dc's main harley quinn
she is incredible she is just as good as kelly
cuoco on the dc animated harley quinn which for
my money is maybe one of the best things dc's ever
done if you haven't seen the harley quinn show
on hbo max it is truly one of the best adaptations
without being too serious of a translation
from the comic books what harley quinn on hbo max
does is it captures the feeling of the characters
in batman from the perspective of harley quinn
batman is kind of a dick and he's a little horny
it's a weird character it's not our batman i
think the smart play is to do the same thing
with todd phillips's joker 2 and have it from
the perspective of harley quinn again and that
keeps you from blending too much in the margot
robbie world that keeps you from blending too much
into the batman world and you've got a fresh new
perspective on what she sees joaquin's successes
as or not we still to this day after watching
joker don't know how much of that was real
how cool is it gonna be to have a new perspective
on how much of that was real by way of her in a
room talking to joker one of the most iconic
scenes in the dark knight is the interrogation
scene give me that again but with harley quinn and
have that break into song so we're not sure how
real that is and that's going to give us a margot
robbie harley that can keep going on in the dc eu
that can grow out to birds of prey too keep going
out and having those tie into the now more loose
shared universe of dc which i honestly think is
one of their strengths and then very intentionally
having a much more harleen quinzell therapist
psychiatrist i'm not sure which one she is they
change it a lot they're very different jobs but
the comic books don't pick one she could either
be a psychiatrist a psychologist or a therapist
we're not sure but i want to see that character
leaning into that side of things she usually uses
her medical background as kind of a punch line
in the in the current margot robbie universe
i want that to be a structure a foundation
of this character here you give me a love story
with joker and harley that's something we haven't
actually seen before there's plenty of fanfics
there's plenty of shots in the jared leto
swimming around a lot of people made some very
sensationalized youtube cuts from the david air
footage we saw we haven't actually gotten to live
in there we've mainly seen her as a figure of
trauma that suffered through the joker let's see
them fall in love let's see that love cloud both
of their judgments it's not a normal thing to fall
so deep in stockholm syndrome you start wearing
makeup i want to see that story we haven't really
seen it since batman the animated series where
she was invented harley quinn is one of the few
characters that actually started outside of the
medium of comic books she was invented in animated
series and was so popular she translated into the
comics she went the other way and now she's in
movies and i think that's a really beautiful thing
to do with joker 2. this is a really special
joke now before i move into the comic book
recommendations what do you guys think about lady
gaga being harley quinn slash harley quinzell what
do you think about being a musical and what do
you think are going to be the influences on this
film since i do think it's going to consciously
be separate from the scorsese joint the first let
me know in the comments i really want to know how
you guys think this casting choice and this tone
choice will affect joker 2. but before i leave
you comic book recommendations my favorite part
of the show because i want to get you reading the
comics that i love so so very much i would highly
recommend there's a comic book from grant morrison
one of my favorite writers of all time called
arkham asylum serious house on a serious earth it
is an insane book with some of the most beautiful
imagery from mckean that is super surrealistic and
super visceral in the way it makes you experience
trauma and insanity and what reality is and i
think that's gonna be a giant influence on this
movie and there's an influence here in the
writing i think is gonna tie into joaquin's
portrayal and that's the idea of super sanity he
introduces an idea that the joker is not insane
he's so sane that he's aware of his own identity
his own physical existence as being laughable to
the point where it almost acknowledges the level
of him being in a comic book it's not deadpool
it's not a fourth wall break in the haha sense
it's a i'm so aware of things i'm so sane everyone
else is insane around me and they strongly
hint at him knowing he's in a fictional world
by way of him being so aware and so intelligent
and so sane this is all madness i could easily
see super sanity being something that ties into
joaquin's joker and i think they honestly hinted
at it in the first film already i think that's
going to be the biggest basis on this story for
joker 2. so check out graham morrison's arkham
asylum a serious house on a serious earth i would
also recommend for a more fun joke or tale there's
a great run called war of jokes and riddles it is
basically joker v riddler and it's showing the
differences in those characters and the whole
story is basically riddler is trying to get joker
to laugh joker's forgotten how to laugh he's lost
to joy ridler is trying to get the laugh out of
the joker i could see that being used for harley
i could see harley trying to get his approval
trying to seek his attention trying to get him
to love her by way of making him laugh i think
that's a very loose tie into the comic book but i
think that main plot point could be utilized it's
also just a bitchin books from tom king one of
my favorite batman writers check out war of jokes
and riddles last two i recommend for you lovelies
brian azarello's joker run brian azzarello
made a trade paperback maxi series it's not in
comics it's it's a book by itself you won't find
floppies of it it's one book just called joker
and it's some of the most stunning imagery of the
joker it looks a lot like that heath ledger joker
but it's nauseating to look at it's very grotesque
it's almost a horrible and it leans into the joker
as his own character he's not fighting batman he's
not doing his own thing and it's how he perceives
the world so the reason the book feels so graphic
is you're looking at it from joker's worldview and
that's a really important distinction for the
character and i'd also recommend the current
run of harley quinn where she is just basically
trying to be good she's trying to absolve herself
from the things that joker made her do and i don't
necessarily think we'll get to that point in the
character but a lot of times the comic books do
allow a certain flavor to be interpreted into
the movies themselves so you might get an idea
of which harley quinn which taken the character
they might be going with plus the animation's
fun it's got a very ties in the hbo max series
a good amount with the style of art and things
so death in the family also badass but i'm
gonna talk about that in another show another
episode down the line but it's very essential
for the joker and they might reference some robin
stuff in this one just like they reference batman
in the first that's gonna do it daily episodes
koi's comic corner every time news breaks we'll
be filming these from boston to my phone i feel
like it's gonna happen thank you for being here
leave a like leave a comment subscribe hit
that bell again if there's anything you
want me to talk about leave a comment below i'm
reading all of them just don't be a dick thanks